humans to Mars does not require building
some gigantic nuclear-powered
interplanetary spaceship we can do it
with the kinds of technology either have
today or know how to build today we need
to have a heavy lift booster would take
to such boosters for each mission the
first one shoots off to Mars an earth
return vehicle so now we have a fully
filled earth return vehicle sitting
waiting for us on the washing surface we
launch two more boosters off the Cape
one shoots out another one in these
earth return vehicle fuel factory
combinations the other shoots out a
habitat with a crew of four astronauts
in it perhaps six we send the crew out
to Mars on a six-month orbit check out
the weather and then go and land at
landing site number one we're a fully
fueled earth return vehicle is waiting
for us the crew would be on Mars for a
year and a half at the end of the year
and a half they get the earth return
vehicle they take off and they fly back
home to earth they leave behind on Mars
their habitat the nuclear reactor their
various ground vehicles other equipment
okay after a number of these things have
done we have a string of bases and after
a little while sending people to stay we
can have build in our time the first
human settlement on a new world there's
nothing in this that is fundamentally
beyond our technology all it takes is
some focus there a little bit of moxie
big news